شتاء دافئ تعيشه اوروبا بفضل نجاح النصائح
والحملات التوعويه من الحكومات والخبراء
الاوروبيين عموما وبالتالي نجاه القاره
العجوز من السيناريو الاسوا وهو ازمه
الطاقه في شتاء قارس وفقا لوصفه جورنا
الامريكيه عن خبراء طاقه الذين يقولون ان
الوعي حول كيفيه استخدام الاوروبيين
للطاقه ومقدار تكلفتها نجح بالفعل وان
الاستجابه كانت لافته للغايه بما فيها
استخدام امدادات بديله وحفظ الاستهلاك
ووفر انخفاض الطاقه مخصونا امنيا مؤقتا
لامدادات الغاز في اوروبا والتي ابتعدت عن
روسيا من لغاز اوكرانيا الى منتجين اخرين
وخاصه الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي انخفض الطلب على الغاز في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بنسبه 20% في الربع
الرابع مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من العام
الماضي وفقا لوكاله الطاقه الدوليه
[موسيقى]